Alright, we've covered a lot of ground. Easily a dozen performance rules.
>> Yeah, to be honest, it's a bit overwhelming. There's a lot to keep in mind.
>> I think I can help you with that. There are a lot of different rules, but
really, there are three buckets into which we can
place most of them. So what do you mean?
>> Well, let's take a look.
>> First, we talked about minifying, compression, and caching.
All three techniques apply to HTML, CSS, and JavaScript.
Next, we know that some resources, namely
CSS, will block rendering. To optimize this, we
talked about two strategies. Use media queries
on link to unblock rendering, and inline CSS.
Finally, we also saw that Javascript blocks
the document parser, which is something we want
to avoid. To fix that, we can defer
Javascript execution, or use the async attribute on
the script tag. So, looking at these, can you spot some patterns?
>> Hm, let's see. Minify, compress, cache, and
minimizing the amount of HTML, CSS, and Javascript.
It's all about reducing the amount of data we have to send down the wire, right?
>> Spot on, that's the first bucket, minimize
the number of bytes. The fewer bytes we need
to download, the faster the browser can get
the data and start processing to render the page.
Any other patterns?
>> Hm, okay, so this one and this
one. Are all about removing files from the critical
rendering path. For CSS there's the media query
stuff, and for JavaScript we have the asyntac word.
>> Exactly. There are many cases where we need CSS
and JavaScript, but there really shouldn't block rendering of a page.
Things like print style sheets and analytics JavaScript code are
both great examples. Our second bucket is to reduce the number
of critical resources.
>> Right, not all resources are critical.
So I guess we should play close attention
to CSS and JavaScript in particular. What's the
third bucket? I don't see anything left here.
>> Right.
>> The last one is, is to shorten the critical rendering path length.
>> Wait, what do you mean by length?
>> Good question. Let's work through some hands-on examples. Let's
construct the critical rendering paths for our hello world page here.
At time zero, we request the HTML. Once
the response arrives, sometime later at time 1. We
parse the HTML and construct the DOM. And
then we render the page to the screen. Note
that there's no CSS or JavaScript. So as soon as we have the DOM, we can render
the page. We do have an image in this
page, but it doesn't block the critical rendering path.
>> That seems pretty straightforward.
>> Yeah,
fair enough. We'll make it more interesting
in a second, but first, let's analyze the
first page against our three buckets. First, how
many critical path resources do we have here?
>> Well, there's only one HTML file, and obviously
we need that to render the page, so. Just one?
>> Yup. We have one critical resource on this
page. Now, how many critical bytes do we have here?
>> Well the HTML's five kilobytes, so five kilobytes?
>> Right again. We have five kilobytes. Now, the last one. In the best case, how
many round trips between the browser and the
server do we need to render this page?
>> Hm, I'm guessing also one. We send the requests to the
server, and we get the response, and I think with that we're good.
>> You're right this time. The HTML file is small then we
only need one route trip to fetch all the data. As a result,
the best case critical path length is also 1.
>> I remember PHP insight said that my page
should ideally be under 14 kilobytes. Is this why?
>> Yes, exactly. And of course if the page is larger the page will
still render, but if the file is large, it'll take more round trips to fetch
the data. And this is pretty low level stuff, but it can make a
big difference in how quickly the page
takes to render. So, check the instructor notes
if you want to learn more. Wait, did you write a book on this?
>> Actually yes, yes I did, and it's available online and it's free. So if
you're curious about this topic you can
learn more about it. Check the Instructor Notes.
>> Cool, yeah, will do.